over on the mass singer no more dancing
or singing for the alien who was
unmasked as LaToya Jackson I just love
this show so much it tickles me
especially my guy Ken Jeong he is so
funny there but now he is taking his
comedy skills back to where it all began
I'd done stand-up comedy for like maybe
like 14 15 years prior to the hangover
so a lot of people don't know that
[Applause]
now Ken standup dreams have come true
with his own Netflix special the title
is pretty crass you complete me ho but
Ken's wife actually suggested it
geez Vietnamese doctor last name ho and
the whole and the joke is you can say
anything you want cuz I'm married a ho
get in the car ho make me some rice ho
just out of curiosity what's your last
name
amid the laughter Ken also gets
incredibly serious and candid in his
routine revealing how his wife overcame
breast cancer ten years ago the fine
needle to thread in terms of comedy is
to try to find light where there is
darkness how you guys got through I mean
did you just bring a lot of comedy to
that situation short answer is yes fact
that I was also a physician and and and
Tran being a doctor we found a way to
break it down medically and after the
first dose of chemotherapy
her tumor responded so we kind of knew
even after the first dose okay you know
we really turn around the core but she
had 12 more rounds of chemo to go [ __ ]
is such like my role model my heel and
if we weren't married I mean she is just
really the strongest person that I know
it was during her chemo when he landed
that iconic role in The Hangover with
his wife still in recovery
Ken's co-star Bradley Cooper stepped in
to help
I drove me from Vegas to LA to be with
Tran and Tran was too weak from the
chemo and couldn't travel so we were in
LA for the holidays and Bradley had us
come over to his place and be with his
family had got me through the most
difficult period of my life
[Music]